we've had some updates from the uk
petrol retailers assists association who
say there are signs that the fuel
situation is improving well it wouldn't
look to be improving by that image that
we're showing you there from west london
but far too slowly they do
acknowledge that is uh north west london
i am told
independent gas stations are not
receiving enough deliveries of fuel
and until those independent gas stations
get sufficient supplies we shall
continue to see those long queues that
we're showing you there from north
northwest london
at the forecourts they have broken down
a little bit of data for us there they
say that 47
of sites have both petrol
and diesel
uh but 26
of gas stations so more than a quarter
have run totally
dry and we can see in the images people
filling up
with jerry cans they're a sign that
things are definitely not getting back
to normal quick enough and 27
of petrol retailers are reporting only
one grade of fuel is in stock at their
forecourt so just a flavor of what's
going on around the country there the uk
petrol retailers saying that things are
improving
it's difficult to see that certainly
looking at the situation here
in north west london but saying that
they are improving too slowly we'll
bring you more on that throughout the
course of the day meanwhile we can bring
in
skies in zamam rasheed who is at a
filling station in chester um in zero
looking at the situation in north west
london certainly doesn't look much
improved what's it like where you are
yeah i think it's interesting hearing
that from the
uk's petrol association about science
that things are improving that's
probably looking at a nationwide picture
and when you come out of london in
particular the the city center you
probably do see that things have been
improving particularly here in the north
of england over uh the last uh a few
days or so there haven't been as many
queues as we saw earlier in the week and
particularly over last weekend as well
when there really was a big rush on the
roads across the country um but even
just speaking to uh the uh the petrol uh
shop lady here she was telling me that
you know it's been fairly busy
over the last week but it has slowed
down over the last few days and i think
that's really important to know that
particularly outside of the capital it
necessarily hasn't been as busy i was in
london over the last couple of days and
did see that it was fairly busy a lot of
petrol stations uh had shut there were
huge queues down some of the main roads
as well causing uh backlogging in
traffic jams but here in places like
chester and over in parts of manchester
where i've been
as well there has been a limit on the uh
the amount of petrol you can put in here
a 30 pound limit they put notices about
why that is happening here and people
have been coming in getting their fuel
and then going away i heard one person
when he went inside to pay he was like
sorry i've gone over by 12 pence they
weren't bothered about that that was
fine but they're trying obviously to
limit the amount of fuel that people
come
and get but hearing that interestingly
from the petrol association that signs
are improving when we listen to what the
government had to say kit malthouse
actually this morning the policing
minister coming on and saying that
actually um we potentially could see
this issue uh for the next week or so
and potentially things could be quite
busy over the next few days again he
probably was
pointing towards the situation in london
in central london where we've seen some
of those pictures sam but it certainly
is looking like outside of the capital
and particularly here in the north of
england that things are stabilizing and
that really is a good sign i think one
note of caution as well we saw uh last
weekend there really was a lot of queues
quite a peaked really last weekend this
weekend potentially we could see
something similar as people gear up for
the start of the week next week but also
people may be wanting to get away this
weekend so i think that is a note of
caution for the weekend but certainly
things stabilizing here in this part of
the region and i'm sure other parts of
the country are still clearly an issue
in the capital